[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans dimanche
en politique votre émission de débat en
franche comté et ce matin on va débattre
de la campagne présidentielle
à cinq semaines tout juste du premier
tour nous avons réuni sur ce plateau 5
soutien des cinq principaux candidats je
vous les présente tout de suite d'abord
antoine chudzik conseiller régional
front national vous êtes partisan de
marine le pen également sur ce plateau
valérie grande et référente
départementale de françois fillon en
côte d'or
il sera temps j'ai président socialiste
du département de haute saône mais
rallié à emmanuel macron une autre
socialiste barbara romagnan vous êtes
député du doubs mais vous une fidèle de
benoît hamon depuis le début de la
campagne des primaires et puis arnaud
glénat dam de la france insoumise le
mouvement de jean luc mélenchon vous
êtes candidat aux législatives en côte
d'or bonjour à tous les cinq
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors vous le savez cette émission c'est
aussi la vôtre vous pouvez interpeller
nos invités commenter le débat sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le modeste qui
s'affiche dean paul bfc comme dimanche
en politique bourgogne franche comté
alors depuis il hier il y a
officiellement aux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle deux seulement
n'avait pas encore eu la parole dans
cette émission il s'agit de jean
lassalle et de jacques cheminade
qualifié in extremis je vous propose
tout de suite de les écouter
le système de verrouillage de l'élection
présidentielle met en place par le
régime des partis n'a pas fonctionné
j'en suis heureux pour le français
d'abord puis pour tous ceux qui sont
parvenus à être candidat tout en le
regrettant
pour certains qu'ils méritaient de
l'être et qui n'y sont pas parvenus
c'est la campagne qui démarre
immédiatement elle est ultra courtes
donc je sais très bien que je ne pas
avoir le temps de me disperser
j'ai quatre semaines pour gagner le
coeur des français
parce qu'il faut que dans cette semaine
ce soit l'elysée
voilà il bien sûr nous allons donner la
parole aux onze candidats ou à leurs
représentants lors de nos deux prochains
débats alors mesdames messieurs avant de
parler de la situation politique
l'actualité nous ramène malheureusement
sur le terrain de la sécurité il ya cinq
ans jour pour jour
mohamed merah s'attaquer à une école
juive à toulouse au nom du djihad
quelques jours auparavant il avait tué
trois militaires
et puis il ya l'aéroport d'orly a été
évacués après qu'un homme s'en est pris
à une patrouille de l'opération
sentinelles l'assaillant a été abattu
valérie grande et la france doit-elle se
résigner à vivre dans la crainte
perpétuelle de nouveaux attentats
en tout cas la menace terroriste pèse
bien encore et toujours sur le sol
français et je crois qu'il hier on a la
preuve qu' on n'est pas du tout sorti de
l'état d'urgence et on doit absolument
mettre en place des mesures et lutter
contre ce fléau qu'est le terrorisme et
qui menace tous les français encore
aujourd'hui avant l'attaqué d'hier le
président de la république avait 10 ans
ont prolongé l'état d'urgence au moins
jusqu'à la mi juillet oui 15 juillet
vous souhaitez qu'il soit prolongé au
delà avec la nouvelle majorité
parlementaire écoute et on verra qui est
qui sera président et quelle quelle est
sa stratégie en matière de lutte contre
le terrorisme que vous souhaitez écouter
tant qu'il ya des menaces qui pèsent sur
la france
on doit maintenir l'état d'urgence
barbara romagnan vous êtes député
socialiste je le disais vous êtes vous
opposé à plusieurs reprises à la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence est ce
que ce qui se passe ces derniers jours
vous fait changer d'avis mais non
d'abord on sait aussi que les
le terrorisme n'est ce pas que les
français et que c'est un phénomène
mondial
à mon sens c'est plutôt la démonstration
du fait que l'état d'urgence ne sert à
rien en tout cas maintenant je crois que
c'est vraiment le cas ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut se résigner mais je pense que
le contexte international fait que ont
exposé à ça donc il faut réfléchir à
l'état de nos relations avec les autres
pays est en tout cas on voit que c'était
inutile que ça a mis en prison dès des
militants surtout que c'était une vraie
atteinte aux libertés publiques et que
par ailleurs sacré de la division dans
la société parce que c'est surtout dans
les quartiers populaires qu'on est allé
faire des perquisitions sans aucun
résultat je crois plutôt que le
renseignement tout cas c'est ce que
disent les spécialistes a besoin de
discrétion de proximité d'où la
nécessité de police de proximité de
renseignement à nouveau de proximité je
pense d'une coopération au niveau au
moins au niveau européen pour échanger
des informations nécessaires
arnaud granata faute il reste quand même
un peu plus les libertés pour plus de
sécurité
certainement pas là où je vais rejoindre
madame romagnan sur la question de la
sécurité de l'état d'urgence
c'est déjà partir du conte du constat
qu'il faut déjà rendre hommage aux
forces sentinelle qui ont gardé leur
sang froid et qui ont permis de répondre
à cette situation et qui ont évité un
bain de sang mais malgré ça c'est
l'épuisement des forces avec la mise en
place de l'état d'urgence qui on le sait
n est efficace que sur les trois
premiers jours contre un état d'urgence
comme son a dit qu'il ne peut pas donc
être permanents et 2 à partir de ces
questions il faut qu'on repense comme
l'a dit la personne en face de moi
repenser aussi notre politique
internationale sur ces questions là mais
ça veut dire qu'il faut plus de
militaires dans la rue de patrouille
parce que mettre fin à l'état d'urgence
c'est aussi ça écoutez j'entendais même
grandet dire il faut recruter des forces
donner les moyens mais attend dès lors
vous êtes représentant de madame de
monsieur fillon monsieur fillon a
supprimé 12000 postes quand il était
premier liste de nicolas sarkozy il faut
revenir au moins à ses effectifs d'avant
2007 c'est au moins ça là dessus au
moins répondre en termes de moyens
humains notamment sur le renseignement
voilà ça c'est la réponse à apporter
pour mettre fin à l'état d'urgence
yves krattinger sur ces questions je
suis pour le maintien de l'état
d'urgence et pour le maintien de
l'opération sentinelle mais l'état
d'urgence c'est censé être une mesure
provisoire là ça fait maintenant des
mois et des mois que ça dure on
on peut prolonger indéfiniment comme ça
parce que effectivement l'épuisement des
forces de l'ordre des forces militaires
tout le monde le constate vos libertés
ont elles été entravée non par contre il
ya une veille indispensable sur
l'ensemble des réseaux de circulation
des personnes est circulation des
informations
c'est nécessaire antoine tudyk marine le
pen s'en est pris au gouvernement hier
soir lors d'un meeting à mais cela dit
qu'il était dépassé à ulrich tétanisé
comme un lapin pris dans les phares
d'une voiture propos outranciers a
répondu le premier ministre bernard
cazeneuve faut-il se diviser sur ces
questions mais il faut surtout apporter
de bonnes réponses et pour apporter de
bonnes réponses il faut faire le constat
le cas du terroriste d'orly il est très
intéressant parce que ziad ben belgacem
il avait quand même à son actif neuf
condamnations
quarante quatre signalements il était
sous contrôle judiciaire et proche de
fichier s ils n'étaient pas fichés
ils n'étaient pas fichés s'il était
proche de fichiers avec ce pedigree
comment se fait-il que ziad ben belgacem
était comme ça en totale liberté sans
absolument aucune surveillance
il avait purgé les vingt deux reprises
ans pour les condamnations 44 finalement
je suis désolé mais il ya quand même un
laxisme d'état en france qui est
absolument insupportable et vendredi
vendredi on n'a pas parlé mais il ya
deux hommes qui ont été égorgés aux cris
de allah akbar à paris qui était
l'égorgeur c'était à tunisien fichier s
comment se fait-il qu'en france on est
des étrangers fiche et est donc
potentiellement dangereux et qu'on ne
les expulse pas c'est absolument
ahurissant je vous rappelle que le 14
juillet dernier quand même à nice le
terroriste mohamed lounes la wave bull
elle était un tunisien qui avait été
aussi condamné cinq fois pour des actes
de violence de vols de dégradations
comment se fait-il que la france qui
quand même n'est pas dans une situation
extraordinaire se se paye le luxe de
garder chez soi des gens aussi dangereux
qu'on pourrait expliquer c'est
absolument ahurissant
barbara romagnan voulait répondre
laxisme dit le front national en tout
cas on voit qu'il ya des partis qui
parle de laxisme de la justice mais qui
ne se rendent même pas aux convocations
des juges donc ça ça me pose vraiment un
problème
quant aux terroristes
quant au test quant aux terroristes
quant aux terroristes où on a bien vu
qu'on était capable de les fabriquer sur
le sol français ça n'a évidemment rien à
voir avec une origine tous les tous les
atouts les non ça n'a rien à voir des
films depuis mohamed merah tous les
terroristes ont ouvert des immigrés ou
bien d'origine milieu maman d'annoncé il
était français ils ont été élevés
d'origine immigrée mais enfin mais vous
croyez que c'est quoi que c'est un jeune
arrive alors sur saône dans mon
département qui se fait sauter et qui
était commun en s'exclamant c'est que
c'est qu'il était parti faire le djihad
est il engagé à vesoul qui sont partis
notamment
mais quel aveuglement fameux le
terrorisme islamiste en france il vient
d'où ce jeu c'est l'islamisme radical en
français par opération du saint-esprit
qui dira pas mais je vous dit non
sélection y avait autant de personnes en
prison en france
oui mais jamais oui mais regardez par
exemple dans les prisons c'est très
intéressant 20% des prisonniers en
france sont des étrangers
il faut se poser des questions et donc
et et donc il faut remettre un peu en
question notre politique d'immigration
massive parce que elle est à l'origine
de nombreux maux en france et ça
personne ne veut le voir valérie grande
d'étrangers en + 8 %
certaines 10% ya un siècle on est face à
un échec de notre politique
d'intégration en france de notre
politique d'accès à l'emploi pour tous
ces jeunes qui sont en train de se
radicaliser
c'est pas des gens qu'on 60 70 ans qui
aujourd'hui occupent d'autres jeux de
musique je pense que la clé la clé
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre cette
radicalisation des jeunes des jeunes
français parce que n'oublions pas en
effet ce sont des français qui attaque
sur le sol français des français et ça
aujourd'hui
posons nous les bonnes questions qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour que ces jeunes quand
dans quelques jours on vous l'a posée la
réponse c'est quoi la réponse c'est une
politique sociale plus adéquate pour
éviter l'exclusion est il
je suis déjà qui a tiré sur ses
camarades il n'avait rien ni d'un
étranger par les fils est grâce à
monsieur et madame je vous redonne la
parole on parle d'attentats de
radicalisation et de suite on parle
d'intégration vous fait le mien aussi
absolument pas je vois pas de lien comme
l'a dit mon collègue
il ya aussi des gens qui sont partis
faire le djihad et qui n'étaient pas
d'origine immigrée j'en ai mal rien
c'est ce que ça veut dire savoir ce que
ça veut dire d'origine immigrée moi je
sais pas ce que ça veut dire moi la
question la question que je pose c'est
pour répondre à ces questions de société
il faut mettre au coeur la question
sociale
il faut apporter des réponses sociales
moi j'en vois plusieurs c'est à voir
c'est relancer la politique économique
pour que tout le monde puisse avoir un
emploi c'est augmenter les salaires
porter le smic à 1350 euros nets
c'est permettre aux gens aussi de partir
à la retraite à 60 ans c'est bref mettre
en place tous les petits bonheurs de la
vie qui vont permettre aux gens de vivre
de manière pacifique et qui vont nous
permettre de faire société ensemble
notamment sur la question républicaine
voilà à cette question se souvient la
tante a jugé le faut qu'on avance sur
les chaussées je suis dit qu on va
avancer avec dans l'actualité de la
semaine une actualité politique qui est
chamboulée par l'actualité judiciaire
valérie grande et françois fillon a été
mise en examen mardi notamment pour
détournement de fonds publics suite aux
révélations de ce qu'on appelle
désormais la sphère pénélope il a choisi
de continuer à faire campagne avec cette
épée de damoclès judiciaire au-dessus de
la tête son image de responsable
politique n'est-elle pas néanmoins
définitivement écornée
en tout cas tout ce qui a été menée
aujourd'hui a été fait en effet pour
affaiblir écorné l'image de françois
fillon concernant la mise en examen de
ce 14 mars
c'est un non événement il l'avait
annoncé le 1er mars
mais c'est quand même un événement est
ce qu'il y ait une affaire bien sûr s'il
avait reçu un pv de stationnement
absolument pas mais monsieur fillon
contrairement à certains s'est présenté
devant devant les juges les nappes de
leurs que s'ils avaient le choix donne
contenu duquel ont déjà pas convaincu en
tout cas cette mise en examen tenu du
calendrier du calendrier judiciaire au
coeur de cette campagne
françois fillon a fait le choix de faire
une déclaration ils avaient le choix de
se taire de répondre aux questions ou de
faire une déclaration
mais le calendrier le calendrier
aujourd'hui de la campagne électorale
l'a obligé
faire une déclaration devant les juges
qui on le savait aller d'autres de
manière automatique le mettre en examen
mais au moins on aura cessé ses avocats
auront accès au dossier
alors nouvelle affaire concernant
françois fillon cette semaine on a
appris qu'il s'était fait offrir pour
13000 euros de costumes de luxe par
l'avocat de la françafrique
monsieur burgi ça commence à faire
beaucoup le parquet national financier
d'ailleurs élargi son enquête à des
soupçons de trafic d'influencé a écouté
tout à fait laissant les sons le parquet
national financiers devraient et
laissons la justice
non je ne dis pas que tout va bien mais
je dis que ça commence à faire en effet
une accumulation importante de fait on
se rend bien compte que c'est un
pilonnage en règle de notre candidat oui
je pense que c'est important que la
justice samantha lisez à important qu'on
ait des visions de la société qui soit
différente mais il ya quand même un
grave problème quand on en est à
remettre comme ça en cause l'institution
judiciaire quand par ailleurs on prétend
gouverner et dire ce qui est bien et ce
qui est mal je pense que pour l'instant
il est innocent mais enfin ça pose quand
même un sérieux problème de crédibilité
par ailleurs il me semble qu'il a eu
aussi des propos avant je mettais pas
permis de le dire mais vraiment indigne
quand on parle de viol de la démocratie
alors que des gens se font vraiment
violet vraiment moi je trouve ça
extrêmement choquant est ce que je
trouve assez pour mon confondant sais
aussi à quel point il semble ne pas se
rendre compte de à quel point c'est
grave on a vraiment l'impression qu'il
ya des gens qui vivent dans des mondes
parallèles
antoine tu dis que la justice
s'intéresse aussi à marine le pen qui
contrairement à monsieur fillon ça a été
dit ne s'est pas rendu à la convocation
des juges d'instruction dans la sphère
de ce qu'on appelle les emplois fictifs
présumés des assistants parlementaires
européens je précise que vous êtes
assistant parlementaire vous même auprès
de sophie montel eurodéputée et
présidente du groupe fn à la région elle
aussi visée par le parlement est
sanctionné financièrement de près de
soixante quinze mille euros
pourquoi marine le pen se soustrait à la
justice pour une raison simple c'est que
effectivement il ya une
instrumentalisation de la justice dans
le pays font encore mais par des juges
militants par des juges membres par
exemple du syndicat de la magistrature
avec leur fameux mur dès qu on jure
quand vous voyez que c'est une enquête
concernant marine le pen par exemple
c'est intéressant ça fait trois ans que
l'enquêté ouverte trois ans il ya treize
mois par le parlement européen d'abord
oui tu sais c est quoi deux ans en
décembre dernier
marine le pen elle a demandé l'ouverture
de la désignation d'un juge
d'instruction il ya treize mois ça lui a
été refusé
elle voulait être entendu par les juges
à 13 mois pourquoi est ce qu'on a refusé
il ya 13 mois et pourquoi comme par
hasard ya là maintenant à quelques jours
des élections présidentielles abane la
procédure s'accélère ce que vous
connaissez la magistrature suprême on
peut remettre comme sa situation est
utilisé par exemple c'est très
intéressant parce que monsieur fillon
lui l' enquête a été ouverte à partir
d'un article du canard enchaîné en une
semaine
pourquoi de cette affaire nous
proposions une sortie par le haut c'est
le sens de proposer une 6ème république
une constituante où c'est le peuple qui
va écrire sa propre constitution reprend
son pouvoir politique et est proposée le
référendum révocatoire pour les élus qui
ont fauté qui sont qui ne sont pas au
clair avec la justice ils doivent
respecter la justice sont une sortie par
le haut et positive que nous voulons
mettre en place avec une 6ème république
il faut que la réponse soit
institutionnels aussi également pour
arrêter d'avoir tout le temps ces débats
entre entre ceux qui sont plus ou moins
pris dans des affaires on n'est pas là
pour ça on est aussi là pour développer
une quantité s'est pas exprimée vision
sociale prend franchement quel que soit
le numéro de la république
l'institution judiciaire doit être
respectée le président de la république
en est le garant
les propos qui sont prononcés à ma
gauche et à l'extrême droite par rapport
à l'institution judiciaire sont
parfaitement inadmissible pour vous la
réponse est nette mais c'est sûr et
certain
excusez moi c'est une des conditions du
fonctionnement de la démocratie d'avoir
une justice indépendante et c'est une
règle c'est pas au dessus des équipes
doivent être partagés au niveau de
l'union européenne pour rester dans les
clous des traités c'est très important
d'avoir un pouvoir exécutif
un pouvoir législatif qui sont
séparé qu'il y ait une justice
indépendante et que les médias soient
libres je rajouterais juste une chose
c'est qu'en effet françois fillon et
respectueux des institutions et
notamment de la solde de l'auto de
l'autorité judiciaire
mais je pense que quelles que soient les
politiques
la présomption d'innocence déjà et d'une
doit s'appliquer
mais surtout on doit ils doivent être
traités comme n'importe quel citoyen
français
voilà et la précipitation l'accumulation
de certaines de certaines charges fait
qu'aujourd'hui on peut avoir quelques
doutes
on avance dans ses missions en danger
vous avez là vous aviez la parole jouent
leur lunch et vous êtes socialiste
président du département de haute saône
ancien sénateur ps
pourquoi ne pas soutenir le candidat de
votre parti benoît hamon
mais en quelques mots je vais être
rapide 1 je ne suis pas adhérent à en
marche et 6 et que je vous voyez
j'encourage à des ateliers ce mot vous
me posez la question c'est y répondre
vous avez appelé les électeurs à voter
pour explique ya le temps je marche et
j'ai pas besoin d'eux qu'on le dise le
marché pour marcher puisque je veux dire
je ne suis pas pour le ni ni
je suis clair aussi je suis pour le fait
est pas la société il ya de bonnes idées
qui viennent de différents endroits fait
pas de partout mais de différents
endroits et je préfère les additionner
que d'exclure le s additionnent le ni ni
exclue je ne suis pas convaincu n'ai pas
réussi à me convaincre
la qualité des propositions de benoît
hamon c'est pas une attaque contre lui
c'est quelqu'un que je respecte et qui
mérite d'être respecté
mais ça veut dire que vous ne respectez
pas dangereux jeu va des électeurs je ne
suis pas prononcé il ya certains m'ont
téléphoné je ne suis plus si vous m'avez
téléphoné mais d'autres je n'ai jamais
dit ce que je faisais dans les primaires
voilà donc je suis resté totalement en
dehors
par contre je répète que je n'ai pas été
convaincu et je ne suis pas apparemment
pas le seul si je dois aller plus loin
jeudi pour moi nous sommes dans une
situation où il ya un avis tempête est
annoncée pour le 23 avril et la réponse
de monsieur macron c'est la loi de
laisser sylla
the deal je sais que je leur tenue hier
lors d'un éventuel à thème après pour le
23 avril
moi j'ai vécu le 21 avril 2002 il ya
plein de gens qui disaient votre et
j'ose pas au deuxième tour et après ils
se sont aperçus que les raisons pour
lesquelles ils sont posés à voter au
premier tour était dérisoire par rapport
aux conséquences du résultat et ils en
étaient eux mêmes complètement abc mais
il s'est vengé ça veut dire que par
exemple los angeles des atomes crochus
avec un jean baptiste lemoyne qui est
questionnée rayon départs ont lieu par
exemple avec barbara romagnan message
l'adhérent du même parti un départ n'est
venu excusez moi c'est pas le problème
je vous demande si vous êtes plus proche
justement je suis tout seul dans ce que
je pense et je suis complètement libre
par rapport à ma pensée et je suis libre
dans les décisions que je prends et
comme ce que je pense à tous les gens me
le demande je l'aurais barbara romagnan
trahison non enfin moi c'est jamais les
terme que j'emploierais je comprends et
je partage la crainte du de choix qu'on
aura au deuxième tour néanmoins je
trouve curieux
indépendamment de ce qu'a pu dire yves
krattinger qui en effet ne s'était pas
prononcée avant pour la primaire de dire
il faut voter pour un candidat pour
éviter une autre
autrement dit marine le pen qui n'est
pas assez démocrates et par là même
s'asseoir sur la démocratie encore une
fois je n'en fais pas une question
personnelle avec yves krattinger qui ne
s'était pas prononcé mais il vient
d'avoir un vote avec deux millions de
personnes qui se sont prononcées donc
c'est quand même un petit peu
contradictoire on a déjà un problème de
légitimité vis-à-vis des citoyens
ça va pas vraiment dans le sens de la
démocratie pariant sur le fond une
question de personne avec yves
krattinger est ce que vous en faites une
question de personne avec manuel valls
car aux fusées de parrainer benoît hamon
cette semaine je pense que c'est que ce
n'est pas correct et que ça n'est pas
comment dire ça n'est pas la bonne
réponse si on veut éviter marine le pen
au deuxième tour
emmanuel macron avec le respect qu'on
peut avoir pour lui propose davantage de
dérégulation alors qu'on a besoin de
davantage de protection et de régulation
moi je crains qu on s'illusionne et que
on se retrouve dans la même situation
que ce qui s'est passé aux états unis où
pensait qu hillary clinton était lagarde
6 anting trump c'est exactement
l'inversé qui s'est passé parce que il
ya tellement de désespérance dans la
société que maintenant si on ne propose
pas un projet qui va gagner l'élection
présidentielle promet en tout cas on a
bien vu qu'il arrive clinton ça ne me
permettait pas ce n'était pas une
garantie contre trump il ya plein de
gens dans la société française
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
permettre la continuation de ce qui
s'est toujours fait barrage à fait quand
même un problème benoît hamon il
rassemble même pas sont quand même pas
s'enflammer mais le col et quand
aujourd'hui ils sont il n'est pas le cas
il n'est pas le représentant du parti
socialiste il a été élu est désigné par
deux millions de personnes je dis pas
qu'on a pas de problème mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la politique elle est
complètement changé ce qui faisait
clivage avant ça a complètement changé
aussi
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut se
mobiliser autour d'un projet qu'il fasse
envie il ya huit millions de gens qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
en france il y en a autant qu'ils sont
toujours dans le risque d'y tomber dont
la majorité travaille il faut faire des
propositions qui sortent de l'ordinaire
de ce qu'on fait d'habitude d'où le
revenu universel d'existence
arnaud granata mon le voit division des
élus au parti socialiste
est ce que jean luc mélenchon s'il
souhaitait vraiment gouverner n'aurait
pas pu trouver un accord avec benoît
hamon écoutez l'avenir commun est sorti
au mois d'octobre il est chiffré se
financer donc nous on est en dynamique
depuis j'ai depuis un certain nombre de
mois maintenant que là vous êtes
condamnés et benoît hamon et jean luc
mélenchon à faire un peu de la
figuration face ben écoutez nous on est
dans une campagne de conviction on a
réuni 130 me soutient hier autour de
thématiques institutionnel pour la
constituante pour se donner de nouveaux
droits seraient définir en tant que
peuple et reprendre notre notre pouvoir
politique en tant que citoyen mais il ya
aussi des divergences avec benoît hamon
on est bien obligé de dire qu'il ya ya
ya des plan programmatique sur la
question européenne
il propose le parlement de la zone euro
respectent et les 3% mais tout ça ça va
lui ça va empêcher benoît monde mettre
en place toute la politique sociale
qu'il est censé vouloir mettre en place
ces différences on vous pouviez pas les
dépasser je pense notamment aux un
bourguignon un arnaud montebourg qui dit
cette semaine sur une radio en matinale
que vous aviez besoin d'eux
de vous unir que vous étiez devant le
mur de l'histoire ça vous interpelle pas
ça écoutez ça interpelle c'est
interpella rno montebourg
nous en tout cas dans la stratégie que
nous voulons mettre en place c'est qu'il
faut faire tenir tête à angela merkel
exigé par exemple la fin de
l'indépendance de la banque centrale
européenne pour que puisse emprunter
pour que nous puissions emprunter auprès
auprès de la banque centrale européenne
sans passer par le montrer pour pouvoir
avoir une politique de relance
économique puisque nous avons besoin
d'une relance économique
donc si on si ici on nous dit mais oui
mais si vous n'arrivez pas à voir les
gars j'ai auprès de auprès d'angela
merkel que ce que vous faites et bien
c'est l'élite hypra et ben justement ça
c'est justement là la stratégie
européenne de benoît m'en dire que ça
sera inopérant puisqu'il ne ne prendra
pas à bras le corps le bras de fer qui
va y avoir à mettre en place au niveau
européen et nous on assure le fait qu'il
faudra un moment donné soit l'europe on
la change on a quitté donc faire une
rupture avec les avec les traités
européens actuels qui empêche de mettre
en place une politique sociale valérie
106 ch vous avez à droite sur cette
année composé sur cette division de la
côte basque déjà là françois fillon est
contestée en interne chez vous mais il
n'a pas de candidat
on est en face il ya un certain voilà
respect des des millions de français
qu'on votait pour lui à la primaire en
effet comme benoît hamon 2 millions nous
plus de 4 millions de français qui se
sont déplacés pour voter et qui ont
largement exprimé qu'il soutenait le
projet de françois fillon
donc voilà il n'ya pas y'a pas photo et
on est tous derrière fillon ce que je
voulais dire à monsieur krattinger c'est
que c'est vrai que monsieur hamon est
dans une position très compliqué puisque
en fait autour de monsieur macron même
si vous dites que c'est aujourd'hui oui
pour vous il lui dit ni droite ni gauche
par contre ce qu'on voit c'est que les
soutiens politiques de monsieur macron
c'est un véritable bureau national du ps
aujourd'hui autour de lui et et sa fin
il ya aussi des gens venus de chez vous
notamment le sénateur de l'yonne avec
monsieur moi personne il a voilà où je
vais vous citer un conseiller
départemental du jura aussi l air qui
rejoint
et maintenant sur tir 102 socialiste
aujourd'hui qu'il ya 400 de socialistes
je crois qu'ils ont rejoint emmanuel
macron de de l air et ben disons deux
électrons libres et on était en liberté
en démocratie et chacun fait en son âme
et conscience et pour répondre
rapidement s'il vous plaît à notre
référent de mélenchon vous de parler de
chiffrage du projet monsieur mélenchon
il ya une chose quand même majeurs qui a
été oubliée c'est qu'en fait il n'a pas
du tout chiffré sa sortie d'une audition
la sortie de l'euro mais personne ne
peut nous obliger à sortir de l'euro
puisque aucun dispositif européen oblige
un pays à sortir de l'euro donc s'il ya
une sortie de l'euro ça sera par
référendum par consultation du peuple
français
aucune raison pour l'instant de parler
de sortie de l'euro puisque personne ne
peut nous en afrique sans faire sortir
de la grande haie antoine je suis dit
qu'il ya eu un scrutin en europe cette
semaine c'était aux pays bas vos alliés
du pvv le parti de la liberté était
donné grand favori par les sondages et
puis finalement ils n'obtiennent que la
deuxième place devancé par les libéraux
et puis surtout on se rend compte qu'ils
ne peuvent pas gouverner sans alliés au
sein du parti ce qu'il ya là un plafond
de verre auquel vous serez aussi
confronté en france
absolument pas le déjà le système
électoral est complètement différent
c'est une élection à un tour et à la
proportionnelle intégrale et puis enfin
monsieur wylder ça peut-être pas gagné
mais enfin ces idées ont largement gagné
parce que le libéral mark rutte
je suis désolé mais vous regardez son
programme sur l'immigration
vive le front national parfois propose
de gagner mais il mais comme en autriche
là où les patriotes sont fort les idées
patriotes sont fortes et le gouvernement
souvent conventions sont obligés de
s'aligner sur les positions patriotes et
en france il ya un problème c'est que la
droite gouvernementale a toujours été
très gauchiste 2010 en termes juridiques
c'est fini allez marine le pen en
parlera sûrement avec francis letellier
dans un instant et puis dans un instant
fabienne acosta pour l'information en
région pour citer bien d'autres après
midi